[Musique]
beaucoup
nous avait promis des voitures volantes
on a eu 140 caractères vous connaissez
peut-être cette punchline de peter chill
le patron de paypal alors je sais peter
t-il c'est une personnalité controversée
on peut lui reconnaître une chose il a
le sens de la formule ce qui est
intéressant avec cette phrase c'est
qu'elles activent tout de suite notre
imaginaire qui en effet n'a jamais rêvé
de monter dans une voiture volante pour
être plus précis qui n'a jamais vibrer
en regardant un film futuriste ou en
lisant un bouquin de science fiction
dans lequel on se déplace tout à fait
naturellement dans des voitures qu'ils
veulent sauf qu'on a eu 140 caractères
enfin 280 maintenant c'est deux fois
plus ça nous fait toujours parler alors
moi je suis pas un buteur thil j'ai pas
investi dans facebook
je ne suis pas libertarien je n'ai pas
envie d'acheter la démocratie et je suis
aussi beaucoup moins fan de
science-fiction que lui mais comme peter
tine
ce que j'aime faire s'est activé notre
imaginaire pour susciter des prises de
conscience pour marquer le coup et les
esprits ça fait même partie de mon
boulot pour tout vous dire
alors tenez par exemple j'essaye de
paraphraser peter tine pour partager
avec vous quelques unes de mes
convictions
ça pourrait donner on nous avait promis
le village mondial
on a cinq média trust qui se partagent
toutes les richesses du web
on nous avait promis une société plus
ouverte plus connectés plus solidaire
grâce à l'économie collaborative on a eu
peur des libéraux airbnb et avec eux une
dégradation sévère de la condition
sociale des travailleurs et dans le
dernier cas des classes moyennes qui
n'ont plus les moyens de
logés dans les centres des grandes
villes encore un on nous avait promis
1984 un régime totalitaire régi par une
intelligence artificielle toute
puissante qui contrôle tous nos gestes
toutes nos pensées tous nos mouvements
on analyse en temps réel toutes les
données que nous laissons derrière nous
et on a eu bien on a eu le scandale
facebook cambridge analytica où l'on
apprend que l'utilisation frauduleuse
des données de 80 millions de personnes
a pu favoriser l'élection de donald
trump ou le breakbeat
on a eu l'émergence d'un totalitarisme
high tech en chine 1 milliard de chinois
sont constamment surveillés aux quatre
coins du pays grâce aux dernières
technologies de reconnaissance faciale
alors je sais je vous brosse là un
tableau plutôt pessimiste mais assez
réaliste la situation et c'est vrai que
dans le même temps
dans le même temps il ya eu plein de
projets enthousiasmants dans le domaine
numérique et il ya aujourd'hui encore
plein de start up pleins de laboratoires
de recherche qui oeuvrent pour le bien
commun
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est
qu'on a assisté ces dernières années à
une crise de confiance majeure est
aujourd'hui nombreux sont ceux qui
pensent que la technologie nous aliène
plus qu'elle nous libère que la
technologie centralise le pouvoir plus
qu'elle ne le distribuer et l'un des
super révélateur de cette crise de
confiance
c'est le succès d'une nouvelle
génération de série de science-fiction
world la servante écarlate et bien sûr
black mirror des séries qui dans la plus
pure tradition de la science-fiction
dystopique nous présente des sociétés
détestable où le bonheur est impossible
et tout ça notamment à cause des
nouvelles technologies
et le pire dans tout ça c'est que si ce
présent et aussi cauchemardesque
et bien c'est aussi un petit peu de ma
faute parce que oui je suis absolument
contre la société de la surveillance
et pourtant j'utilise google maps au
quotidien ce qui permet à google
d'enregistrer mes déplacements au
quotidien alors par heure et ce depuis
des années parce que oui je suis
absolument contre les facs news je pense
même que les fait mieux ce sont toxiques
pour notre démocratie
et pourtant je clique souvent sur ces
informations
rigolote mais pas très crédible et ce
faisant je nourris des algorithmes qui
constatant la popularité de ce contenu
eh bien vous le rendre encore plus
visible auprès d'une audience encore
plus importante
parce que oui j'ai pas envie que demain
ma vie soit régi par une intelligence
artificielle toute puissante et pourtant
j'alimente à longueur de journée des
bases de données gigantesques rien qu'en
envoyant des mails ou en commandant des
couches pour monfils sur amazon
or c'est grâce à ces bases de données
monumentale que les algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle deviennent
toujours plus puissants toujours plus
performants vous l'avez compris nous
sommes non seulement ces séries de
science-fiction l' angoisse mais elle me
désigne l nous désigne comme les
complices d'une déshumanisation
galopante un pas
c'est sympa et c'est surtout hyper
paralysant parce que si je suis moi pour
peser sur ces dérives
j'ai supprimé mon compte facebook ouais
c'est une piste mais il restera quand
même plus de 2 milliards et au delà de
ça puisque l' accélération technologique
est tellement importante que je n'arrive
déjà pas à suivre et anticiper les
effets néfastes de mes usages du
numérique
aujourd'hui comment pourrais-je peser
sur ceux qui vont se développer demain
alors comment faire et bien
paradoxalement je pense que face à ce
vertige
l'une de réponse
c'est précisément la science fiction
arrêtons de mettre la technologie au
procès arrêtons de nous demander si
black mirror est en train de devenir une
réalité
la science-fiction assad génial
elle se fiche complètement de savoir si
une technologie sera au point dans 25 50
ou 100 ans
la technologie se fiche complètement de
notre capacité à suivre l'accélération
technologique la science fiction se
fiche complètement de notre capacité à
suivre l'accélération technologiques en
revanche ce qu'elle peut faire
d'exceptionnel ce qu'elle génère chez
nous des émotions puissantes qui nous
projette très très loin qui réactive
notre imaginaire et qui nous permettent
d'imaginer les différents futurs
possibles
en bref la science fiction nous permet
de rêver
ce que nous n'arrivons pas encore à
concevoir réactiver son imaginaire pour
rêver ce que nous n'arrivons pas encore
à concevoir ça peut paraître un peu
naïve dit comme ça et pourtant ça marche
en tout cas ça a marché pour martin
cooper martine compain vous le
connaissez peut-être pas c'est celui qui
a inventé ce que vous avez tous dans
votre poche
le téléphone portable il l'a créée en 73
1973 quand il était ingénieur chez
motorola et il a tout de suite précisé
qu'il s'était fortement inspiré du
communicateur du capitaine kirk dans
star trek pour mettre au point son
invention
ça a marché aussi pour elon musk le
patron de tesla répète à longueur
d'interviews qu'il a été profondément
marqué par la lecture du guide du
voyageur intergalactique
quand il était ado c'est un bouquin de
science-fiction loufoque qui l'a aidé je
le cite à construire sa vision du monde
et sa compréhension de l'univers
rien que ça mais en fait je pense que ça
a marché pour chacun d'entre nous en
tout cas ça a marché pour moi avec les
voitures volantes
je devais avoir cinq ou six ans la
première fois que j'ai rêvé de voitures
volantes
c'était en regardant le doc et marty
voyager dans le temps à bord de leurs
delorean de retour vers le futur à 11
ans je me rêvais en korben dallas aux
manettes de mon taxi volant comme dans
le cinquième élément et ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'aujourd'hui alors que
sortent les premiers prototypes de
voitures volantes et bien je me rends
compte que j'ai absolument pas envie
d'en avoir une mais c'est pas ça qui
compte
ce qui compte c'est quand rêvant devant
ce film quand j'étais gamin je me suis
construit ma propre vision du futur un
futur dans lequel on se déplace plus
rapidement plus facilement un futur dans
lequel on voyage plus souvent plus loin
à moindre frais un futur dans lequel on
reste constamment en contact avec ses
proches et ce où qu'ils vivent dans le
monde
en bref un futur dans lequel on a réussi
au moins en apparence à s'affranchir des
contraintes du temps et de l'espace
et tout ça notamment grâce à 140
caractères
alors au final peu importe que la
science fiction soit prophétique ou non
seule compte sa capacité extraordinaire
à nous sortir de la panne du présent à
réactiver notre imaginaire à nous faire
rêver des différents futur dans lequel
nous voulons vivre à nous aider à
imaginer une destination et imaginer une
destination se forger un destin
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à